The macho man, Russo brothers.
How do you guys not have any Nova Corp member
in a fight against Thanos?
Love the movie, but just boggles my mind.
Didn't even have to be Richard Ryder.
I look closely at that scene again there
and you will see there are thousands of people.
Yeah, you will see Richard Ryder
in the background of a shot
Easter egg everyone, thank you so much.
These were great questions.
Yeah, yeah. Sending in these questions.
We really appreciate it.
And hopefully you got satisfactory answers.
Yeah.
And I hopefully you have answers of your own.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
And it looks like Marvel has found their new
Nova in the MCU
I know everyone's been asking
when he's going to show up
since the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
happened back in 2014.
In Marvel, started doing more space based movies.
There were a couple of times
Marvel almost wound up using the character in movies,
but swapped them out for other characters
at the last minute.
So we'll break it all down.
uses it to picture him
coming up with whole new meme formats during all this.
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We have a bunch of big stuff
coming up like the Deadpool three trailer.
In fact, one of the reasons why you haven't seen
Nova before now involves Ryan Reynolds.
I'll talk about that during the video, too,
because it's is kind of funny.
blaming
some of this on Ryan Reynolds in a funny kind of way.
But if he didn't see the news,
we just learned about Ryan
Gosling meeting with Kevin Feige
about becoming Nova in the Marvel movies.
And even though I know a bunch of people have been fan
casting him as the new Johnny Blaze,
ghostwriter of the MCU
in Marvel will introduce a new ghostwriter soon.
They're setting up more supernatural, darker
characters.
Teams like the Midnight Suns.
Apparently Kevin Feige wanted Ryan Gosling as Nova or
Ryan Gosling wanted Nova himself.
Because actually, Marvel does that a lot more than you
realize.
Were actors like Keanu Reeves, for instance,
who people have been fan casting as Ghost?
Meet with Marvel every couple of years like clockwork.
Kevin Feige
revealed a couple of years ago
that they met with Keanu Reeves on the regular,
like every couple years, just about
opportunities, characters that he could play.
So it's not always the exact same character
when you're talking about Keanu Reeves.
And it's the same for a lot of other major actors, too.
Usually during those meetings, there's characters
that Marvel wants them to play,
or there's characters that the actors are just fans of
in real life that they want to play.
That's how
Mahershala Ali wound up
becoming the new blade of the MCU because he went to
Kevin Feige and was like, I want to play a character
and I want it to be Blade and Kevin Feige
was like, Sure, why not? Let's do it.
in the funny thing about Richard Ryder Nova is that
he was supposed to be in Avengers Infinity War.
In Avengers Endgame.
Both the writers of those movies, Marcus and McFeely,
and then the Russos talked about the scenes
his Avengers,
Infinity War deleted scene would have set up his return
during Avengers Endgame in that final battle
where the portal scene happens.
This is the Russos talking about that.
look closely at that scene again there
and you will see there are thousands of people.
Yeah, you will see Richard Ryder
in the background of a shot
Easter egg even though they're being kind of jokey
when talking about it, kind of sarcastic.
Zoom enhanced.
He's not in the theatrical version,
so you wouldn't actually find him
in the final version of the movie
that we all see on home video Originally,
what was supposed to happen
is that during Avengers Infinity War
they had a totally different opening scene
in the theatrical cut.
They just opened on Thanos in the Black order,
attacking Thor's as guardianship,
killing half the people, killing Loki. R.I.P.
Taking the space Stone Originally, the writers revealed
what was supposed to happen
is that we would have seen the story of how Thanos
got the power stone from the Nova Corps
because when he attacks Loki in Thor,
he already has it in the Infinity Gantlet.
after the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie,
Star-Lord gives the power stone to Nova Prime,
Glenn Close, his character for safekeeping,
and she puts it in deep storage under guard on Zander.
then we never see it again
until it's on Thanos hand in the Infinity Gantlet.
So according to the writers,
what would have happened is that Thanos would have led
an all out assault on Zander
in, like the opening 5 minutes or so of the movie,
basically destroyed the entire Nova Corps, laid
waste to the planet, and taken the power stone.
Then he goes after Thor
and Loki to get the space stone.
But after Thanos would have taken the power stone
leaving the planet, we would have seen Richard Ryder
crawl out of the ashes,
being the only survivor of Thanos attack.
And that would have served
as the beginning of his origin story in the MCU.
they would have had to change his origin story
a little bit for the MCU, but that's nothing new.
They do that all the time in Marvel movies.
In the comics.
Richard Ryder originally was a normal human from Earth
who's chosen by Roman Day
to take the power of the Nova force.
Passing his powers to him
then goes on to kill the being who killed
Roman Day is probably clicking in your minds
like instantly.
You can see why Marvel wanted to change
Nova's origin story in the MCU and use Stannis attack
Because it's basically the exact same origin story
as Green Lantern Hal Jordan.
And they just done this version on screen years ago
with Ryan Reynolds.
that's one of the reasons
why you don't see Richard Ryder
in that first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
because that came out in 2014.
It would have been too soon
after the Green Lantern movie came out and then Bond,
Ryan Reynolds didn't really redeem himself
with the first Deadpool movie until 2016.
A couple of years later.
blame Ryan Reynolds for
Nova not appearing in that first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie, But they did have a couple plot
elements from Richard Ryder's Origin story
that James Gunn did introduce in that movie.
for example Roman Day,
the person who held the Nova force.
That passage, Richard Ryder, was played by John
C Reilly in the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie.
So you already have some of the characters
there for his origin story.
But either way, after Thanos destroys the Nova core,
Richard Ryder becomes the sole recipient
of the Nova force, making him way more powerful
because the power is in being divided
between a legion of different people,
it'd be kind of like how Jordan wielding the power
of all of the green Lanterns by himself,
he would have gone on his revenge quest
that would have culminated
during the Avengers endgame final battle.
So when the Russos said that he was
in that portal scene, they were half telling the truth.
He would have been in the scene
had they not already gotten rid of his introduction
at the beginning of Avengers
Infinity War, in part of the reasons
why they got rid of those NOVA scenes are two
one speed up the plot in Avengers Infinity War.
They already thought that is interesting,
which is way too much for the movie to handle
because there were so many characters in that movie
and it was already a super long movie
Then when they got to that final battle
in Avengers Endgame,
it didn't make sense to include him
because you got rid of his introduction scene.
So already
people would have no idea who the character is
that he showed up in the background like,
if you're a hardcore fan, you'd see.
But most casual audiences be like,
Who the hell is that and to boot.
They also wanted Captain Marvel being the person
coming in at the last minute during that battle.
So essentially,
Captain Marvel replaced Nova in the storyline,
And that's one of the other major reasons why
Marvel's waited so long on doing Nova in the movies,
because a lot of Nova's villains
have been in the Captain Marvel movies already.
they've been trying to push Captain Marvel
so hard since Avengers Infinity War with that teaser
introduction or space pager that her solo movie,
The Endgame, seen her showing she post-credits scene.
The Marvel's movie.
if you haven't read them, There have been entire books
the last couple of years
about the secret history of the MCU,
what their long term plans have been, how they changed
all of them and back during Avengers Infinity War
when they were still filming.
Those movies like this is all still in production.
No joke.
They wanted Spider-Man.
Chadwick Boseman's Black Panther in Captain Marvel
to replace
the six main Avengers
as the new core foundational pillars of the MCU.
Everything going for like all the Marvel
Phase four, Phase five,
Phase
six story would revolve around those three characters.
cut to.
A couple of years later,
we saw how that all wound up playing out.
Chadwick Boseman passed away in real life.
May he rest in power.
No more black Panther.
The way that Marvel wanted him to become Sony got pushy
with Spider-Man in Marvel
almost completely lost usage of the character.
Their sharing deal is still kind of tenuous at best.
Like the only do it for one movie at a time
and a couple of cameos
and then they have to sign a new sharing deal.
And that includes Spider-Man four right now, Avengers
five and Avengers six.
So there is no Spider-Man
five on the books at Marvel yet.
meaning that Kevin Feige can't really make the long
term plans he wants to make with that career.
Like he can't make him
a core foundational aspect of the MCU
unless they completely have control of the character.
don't want to go on making a whole bunch of plans
and having to change those the last minute
because they might lose the character to Sony again
and for whatever reason, Captain Marvel just has
not landed with audiences the way that Marvel wanted
to, or Brie Larson hasn't been the right fit for this.
There's been talks about her
not being super happy with the way things
have played out on her end of things,
She's a great actress in her own right.
BRIDGES For whatever reason, it has just not worked out
with that character the way Marvel has wanted it to.
So it's not like
she can exactly become the center of the MCU anymore.
So this is why Marvel has been so chaotic
during Marvel Phase four of the present day.
All the stuff with Jonathan Majors
and his legal issues are just a recent occurrence
that have compounded all the problems
Marvel's had to deal with.
Stevie Wonder.
Why up to recently it's felt like a mess at Marvel.
There's just been so many different surprise problems
that they did not expect and had to deal with
that has got real real hard for them
to do what they want to do.
but essentially the Nova character is
they'd intended him like way back in the day
just all too similar to what was going on with
Captain Marvel the way they were using that character
and because they'd been pushing her character,
they wanted to focus on her so much.
They just kept delaying Nova's introduction.
Right now with the Marvel's movie
not panning out the way they'd intended, it
looks like Marvel might not make Captain Marvel three.
they'll probably pivot with her character
and use her in other future movies
in apparently they decided
now is the fine time for Nova.
Like we're not going to be using Captain Marvel
nearly as much.
There's room for Nova here's the thing, though.
There's a number of different ways
you could actually bring the Nova character in
and characters
that you can use him with in the space based movies.
we're supposedly going to see more from Rocket's
New Guardians of the Galaxy team
that we saw at the end of Guardians three.
James Gunn said that he expects Marvel
to continue that team in future movies,
but they won't do Guardians of the Galaxy for
I would say do a Nova movie.
Just use Rocket's Guardians team during that,
pairing them up with him
because they have such a connection with Zander
in the Nova Corps in the movie's already
they even just did a Nebula episode
of whatever season two
where she became Nova essentially inside the MCU.
She's the leader of nowhere,
but she'll come back in the live action movies, too.
Karen Gillan says she'll stick around as long as Kevin
Feige will have her, so she's not going anywhere.
like I said, though, there are a lot of Nova villains
they've already used in the Captain Marvel movies.
But going forward you can actually use a nihilist
in the Annihilation wave.
Really big character that Marvel's been waiting on.
But here's the other thing, too.
James Gunn said For a while
there were a lot of deleted scenes
featuring a nihilist in Guardians of the Galaxy three.
So already.
They were almost going to introduce the character.
Let me know in the comments, though.
If Marvel introduces the Nova character,
how do you want them to use him in the MCU?
Just in general, like space based movies, Big Avengers
level movies?
Just post all your theories in the comments below.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We have a Deadpool three trailer coming really soon.
I just did a big video about all the scenes
they just released.
Click here to learn about that and click here
for that other new Deadpool 3 teaser trailer.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!